Shooting a watermelon off your brother's
head and an inverted sandwich.
I'm a little sick today,
but the best medicine is episode 37
of IMG!
Why is this cat so sad? Does he not
know that unicorn bicycles exist?
The only thing more spectacular
might be this 'Jaws'
themed swimsuit with The Little Mermaid
as the victim.
Or maybe the answer is this bubble.
What do you think, shocked barn?
Huh, always surprised.
Well, this toilet thought it was funny
and, as usual, chocolate chip cookie's just
grumpy. But it could be because someone
just threw
acid on his wife's face.
It's not funny, bag.
MoIllusions.com featured a tree's
shadow that produces a
face. Of course, some shadows prefer
beer pong. I mean, like, they really
love it.
Reflections can be just as naughty.
This word became "nude."
But whatever,
the final boss of the Internet prefers
dogs making awkward smiles.
Enjoy.
On DeviantArt Katie created out of this world lips,
a sunset face and eyes based on the Lion King
and Alice in Wonderland.
But now, what the H is
this?
Oh. A mirror
lake.
This graffiti uses its surface creatively
and here's a real-life angry bird attack.
This tree looks like it has teeth, a tongue and
vomit.
And this shirt makes your arm a horse neck.
Researchers in China are trying to reintroduce
captive bred
pandas into the wild without wild
pandas knowing the difference.
Their solution? Dress up like pandas,
which leads to awesome pictures
like these. Heart hair. On Facebook.com/VsauceGaming
Avery did some important math.
And Raman added this illusion,
where your brain can't help but see the
two groups shake around,
even though they're not moving.
Like us on Facebook to see more
or to submit your own.
And as always,
thanks for watching.